think dirty app and it'll tell us if the
ingredients aren't good or not apps like
think dirty and yuca that rate how clean
beauty products are are incredibly
inaccurate they're mostly based on the
appeal to nature fallacy and they keep
getting really basic things wrong for
example sodium lauryl sulfate is rated
as a 4 which is moderately dirty because
it says it's contaminated with 1 4
dioxane this is a carcinogen that's
sometimes an impurity in ethylene oxide
which is used to make some ingredients
but first off one full dioxane is very
carefully monitored in cosmetics it's
limited to less than 10 parts per
million which is safe but secondly
sodium lauryl sulfate isn't even made
with ethylene oxide so there's no one
for dioxin contamination issue and then
ingredients that are made with ethylene
oxide aren't flag for 1 4 dioxane again
it isn't actually a safety issue but if
they say it is they should at least get
that right
safety isn't as straightforward as red
yellow green you need to consider the
dose and concentration and you just
can't get that off an ingredient list it
isn't that surprising that a company
that thinks safety is this simple is
making these basic mistakes